Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. In Australien ist die australische A-League mit einem denkwürdigen Finale vorbei gegangen. Ach, wenn man darüber doch mit jemandem sprechen könnte, zum Beispiel mit Thomas Broich, dem dreimaligen australischen Meister. Das wäre schön. Huch, da ist ja jemand in der Leitung. Thomas, sei mir gegrüßt.
Hi.
Sehr schön, dass du mal deine Premiere im Rasenfunk gibst. Ich freue mich sehr, Thomas Broich hier begrüßen zu dürfen, denn du hast ja, wie hoffentlich alle Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, einen ausgeprägten Bezug zur australischen Fußballliga. Genau, sieben Jahre von insgesamt gibt es die Liga jetzt, glaube ich, im 13. Jahr jetzt dann. Also du bist auch noch in der Mehrzahl der Geschichte mit dabei gewesen. Wie ist denn das, wenn du jetzt so ein Finale verfolgst? Du hast es auch als Experte bei der Zone kommentiert. Ist das dann so eine Reise zurück in die Geschichte zu deinen eigenen drei Final-Teilnehmen? Wie erlebst du sowas?
Ja, das auf jeden Fall. Also es war wirklich ganz witzig, dass man sich natürlich an diese Tage von damals erinnert. Zum anderen merke ich auch, dass ich da emotional echt involviert bin, was das Leistungsvermögen der Liga angeht. Also wenn ich dann da bei der Zone sitze und am kommentieren bin, dann würde ich mir natürlich auch wünschen, dass die Jungs da richtig einen raushauen. Da war ich ehrlich gesagt auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass das Finale fußballerisch überschaubar war. Da kann die A-League eigentlich echt viel mehr und sowas tut mir dann selber auch ein bisschen in der Seele weh.
Wo würdest du denn die A-League vom Niveau her ungefähr einordnen, wenn wir es jetzt mal mit der Bundesliga, 2. Liga und so weiter vergleichen?
Also ich glaube, da brauchen wir uns nichts vormachen. Alles in einem ist die A-League natürlich nicht wirklich so konkurrenzfähig. Also wenn man jetzt einschätzen müsste, ich würde sagen ungefähr unter das 2. Liga Niveau.
Unter das 2. Liga Niveau. Und welches Niveau hatte dann dieses Finale? Es traten an Newcastle United Jets gegen Melbourne Victory.
Das Problem war, dass die im Moment hier alles überragende Mannschaft total überraschend im Halbfinale ausgeschieden ist. Das ist Sydney FC, die wirklich ein Rekord nach dem anderen gebrochen haben und auch echt schicken Fußball gespielt haben. Die hatten da, ich glaube, einen Serben, einen Brasilianer drin, einen Pole, der lange bei der Türkei aktiv war. Also Jungs, die sich in Europas Top-League auch gut getummelt haben, Champions League vergangenheit hatten. Und ja, also denen macht es richtig Spaß, zuzuschauen, nur die waren leider im Finale nicht dabei. Und es war dann eher ein Außenseiterteam mit Newcastle United und dann Melbourne Victory, was schon – die Australier nennen das Powerhouse – so der FC Bayern ein bisschen Australiens ist. Aber die hatten auch keine gute Saison. Also das heißt Überraschungsteam und eine Mannschaft, die eigentlich mit Tabellenplatz 4 nach der Regular-Season ein bisschen enttäuscht hat, die aber jetzt doch Meister geworden ist. Und genauso war das Finale dann auch. Also da hat die spielerische Qualität ein bisschen gefehlt.
Und alles wurde schon sehr früh entschieden. Es ging 1 zu 0 aus und der Treffer hat es ein bisschen um die Welt geschafft. Nicht weil er besonders schön war, sondern weil drei Spieler gleich im Upside standen, als dieser Treffer fiel, der letztlich ja dann das Finale entschieden hat. Und jetzt muss man dazu sagen, es gibt den Videobeweis in Australien. Was zur Hölle ist denn da schief gelaufen?
Der ist ausgefallen tatsächlich. Also die A-League hat dann auch ein Statement veröffentlicht, das just in diesem Moment sich total versorgen wird. Und zum ersten und einzigen Mal in der Saison einfach der Feed hin zu diesem WLA da ausgefallen ist.
Wahnsinn, Wahnsinn. Wie gehen die australischen Medien mit so was um? Man muss ja dazu sagen, Fußball ist da nicht die wichtigste Sportart, anders als hier bei uns in Deutschland. Gibt es da dann einen großen Aufschrei? Wird die Video-Debate ähnlich emotional geführt wie hier bei uns?
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Wir waren damals so ein bisschen die Versuchskaninchen. Wir sollten das Ding testen, bevor es in die großen Ligen nach Europa rübergeschwappt ist. Ich habe das als super angenehm empfunden, weil du dir denkst, wenn da jetzt zehn diskutable Entscheidungen sind, dann kriegst du es wahrscheinlich doch mindestens acht bis neunmal richtig hin. Vorher war es bei wirklich diskutablen Sachen eher so eine 50-50-Sache. Also es hat sich irgendwie echt so angefühlt, dass es gerechter zugeht und dass es auch weniger Notwendigkeit gibt, sich auf dem Platz total aufzuführen. Also diese Diskussion, die es ja früher gab mit Abseite und Elfmeter und so, wo dann Leute im Quadrat gesprungen sind und mit dem Schiri angegriffen haben, irgendwie hatte ich das Gefühl, so in Australien, wenn du gefault worden bist um 16. Dann vertraue ich darauf, dass der Refter auf der Tribüne oder hinter dem Stadion das sieht. Und dann kriege ich meinen Elfer oder halt nicht. Also ich habe das sehr angenehm davon. Aber das liegt natürlich daran, dass es im Nachlauf auch nicht so krass diskutiert wird wie in der Bundesliga.
Und seit wann gibt es den Videobeweis in der Australischen Liga?
Die haben den, ich glaube, vor anderthalb Jahren eingeführt. Also wir hatten den, glaube ich, in der letzten Saison durchgängig. Ich war ja selber schon nicht mehr aktiv, aber der wurde so Anfang, Mitte der Saison davor schon eingeführt.
Und deswegen hast du noch einige Spiele mit Videobeweis dann mitbekommen, bevor du dann deine Karriere beendet hast, deine aktive Karriere. Okay, lass noch mal kurz auf diesen Sieger Melbourne Victory zurückzukommen. Du hast schon gesagt, ein bisschen das Powerhouse der FC Bayern der Australischen Liga. Wie auch immer man jetzt das verstehen möchte, im Positiven oder im Negativen. Ist es denn unter dem Strich dann schon irgendwie verdient? Wie stehst du denn zu so einem Playoff-System, um den Meister auszuspielen?
Ja, ich bin da innerlich ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Also so eine Liga wie die australische, die lockt da jetzt nicht so viele Leute in den Stadion. Das muss man ja wirklich auch ganz ehrlich sagen in der Regular-Season. Also du hast dann oftmals bei Vereinen Zuschauerschnitts von Mariners, glaube ich, sind traditionell schlecht. Die haben eher so 5.000, 6.000. Victory hat wahrscheinlich dann doch eher 15.000. Aber zu den Finals hast du dann plötzlich eine Ausverkauf die Bude. Also der australische Fußball oder der australische Sport, der braucht das. Und der lebt diese Art von System. Also das ist ja nicht nur beim Fußball, sondern kommt ja vor allem aus dem Rugby auch. Oder AFL, dass diese spezielle Rugby-Art in Australien gespielt wird. Ich glaube, dass es notwendig ist für die Australier gerade in diesem Moment. Aber das ist natürlich nicht immer gerecht zu geht. Also wie gesagt, also Sydney FC spielt eine überragende Saison. Seit zwei Jahren wirklich das beste Team.
Das Einzige, was sie bekommen, ist, dass sie in der AFC Champions League mitspielen dürfen. Das bleibt ja bei demjenigen, der der erste der Regular-Season ist und nicht derjenige, der den Titel bekommt, richtig?
Die anderen rücken aber dann auch nach. Und derjenige, der das Final qualifiziert, gewinnt, qualifiziert sich dann auch noch für die Champions League. Das heißt, du kommst so oder so da rein. Aber was die Champions League angeht, da muss man sich ja eher auch die Frage stellen, das ist jetzt Fluche, deswegen. Also das hört sich erstmal geil an und macht natürlich auch Spaß, sich mit den besten Teams Asiens zu messen. Das natürlich auch bedeutet, dass du dann plötzlich gegen auch internationale Topstars spielst, die sich ja plötzlich da in der Liga rumtummeln, wird es ja so in Australien eher schwerer begegnen. Dann spielst du auf einmal gegen Carlos Teres oder so. Das ist natürlich die geile Sache für die Jungs aus Australien. Auf der anderen Seite, die reisen halt da immer 16 Stunden im Flieger, Economy Class, am besten dreimal umsteigen und dann auch mal Bus irgendwo hin und dann irgendwo in der koreanischen Provinz zu spielen.
Ja, also die LFC Champions League ist nochmal so ein eigener Wettbewerb. Da muss ich irgendwann nochmal eine Folge zu machen. Ich habe mir jetzt nur gerade das Achtelfinale gezogen. Das wird gerade ausgespielt. Da spielt er dann Al Jazeera gegen Parsepolis, Buriram United gegen Jeroenbouck Motors. Ah, gut, ganz eigenes Thema. Wer sind denn gerade so in der australischen Liga die bekanntesten Spieler? Ich würde jetzt mal vermuten, bei so einer jungen Liga und auch wenn man nicht die Nationalsportart Nummer 1 ist, geht es ja wahrscheinlich noch viel über die Persönlichkeiten, die in der Liga spielen.
Ja, witzigerweise würde ich sogar sagen, das ist wahrscheinlich jemand, den man aus Deutschland noch kennen könnte, der besser als Berisha, der früher beim HSV, den man versucht hat, als junger Spieler. Später war er auch noch in Bielefeld, der ist mittlerweile so was wie der Gerd Müller Australiens. Ich glaube, das war sogar letzte Saison, dann irgendwann Anfang der Saison, zum alleinigen Rekordtorschützen gemacht. Und der ist auch erst sieben Jahre mit dabei. Wahnsinn. Und hat jetzt alle anderen bei Weitem überflügelt. Und der ist schon so ein bisschen ein Held. Und der hat mittlerweile vier Grand Finals gewonnen.
Wahnsinn, das kann man sich kaum vorstellen, wenn man sich an seine Hamburger Zeit zurückerinnert. Nicht, dass er da jetzt total schlecht gewesen wäre, aber er hat gar nicht so viele Spiele da bekommen. War von 2004 bis 2007 da und hat nur zwölfmal gespielt, dann einen Treffer erzielt. Und du hast aber mit ihm zusammen bei Brisbane Roar noch gekickt, oder?
Wir haben zwei Jahre oder drei sogar zusammengespielt. Wir sind zweimal Meister geworden zu der Zeit. Das hat natürlich echt gut gekostet, weil er hat ja schon wirklich die Qualität eigentlich auch woanders zu spielen. Und für mich war es in der Liga natürlich auch viel, viel leichter als in Deutschland. Und da haben sich echt zwei nicht unbedingt gesucht, aber gefunden.
Ja, so hört es sich ein bisschen an. Unfassbare Torquoten hat er. Also hat bei Brisbane damals in 65 Spielen 41 Tore gemacht und jetzt bei Melbourne Victory in 82 Spielen 54. Also der Gerd Müller-Vergleich, da passt er mal halbwegs, das muss man sagen. Und sehr, sehr gutes Fußballkneipen wissen. Wer ist der Rekorder-Schütze der australischen Liga? Besad Barisha. Jetzt wisst ihr es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Wie beurtest du denn das Abschneiden von deinem ehemaligen Verein, also Brisbane Roar, die jetzt auch bis in die Elimination Finals gekommen sind, was so die Vorstufe zum Halbfinale und zum Finale ist?
Ja, man muss leider sagen, dass wir nicht nur dieses Jahr, wo ich jetzt nicht mehr aktiv sein soll, sondern auch schon die letzten zwei, drei Jahre so ein bisschen auf dem absteigenden Ast waren. Also es galt jetzt schon so ein bisschen als Erfolg, dass man sich am Ende noch für die Finals qualifiziert hat. Das heißt, du wirst Sechster von Zehn. Und das als ehemaliger Champion und Rekordmeister, der wir in bestimmten Zeiten auch waren, auch wenn es nicht viel heißen muss. Aber der nächste schon, dass im Moment die Ansprüche ganz schön zurückgegangen sind. Und Spieler des Jahres, also das wird immer intern ausgezeichnet, wurde dieses Jahr dann zum ersten Mal auch eine Torhüter. Und da blutet mir das Herz schon so ein bisschen, weil wir wirklich für offensiv Fußball standen, wir haben uns Barcelona genannt, weil wir damals als Erste in Australien versucht haben, so etwas wie Tiki-Taka auf den Platz zu legen. Wir hatten echt Ballbesitzquoten wie Barcelona und haben die Liga total dominiert. Und fairerweise sollten wir wirklich sagen, das ist in den letzten drei Jahren schon nicht mehr der Fall. Aber es ist halt so ein schleichender Verfall, und wenn man dann so lange bei einem Verein war, so darf es natürlich ein bisschen weh.
Ja, das glaube ich. 7 Jahre, 181 Spiele hast du für Brisbane Raw-Salona, wie ich jetzt gelernt habe, gemacht. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Wie war denn so damals für dich die Akklimatisierung an die australische Liga im Jahr 2010?
Schwer, leicht zugleich. Also wenn du jahrelang halt Bundesliga spielst und suchst dich gar nicht schwer, kommst du dann in eine Mannschaft, wo du nach wie vor ein Potenzial hast, aber plötzlich ist alles um dich herum, plötzlich langsamer und halt nicht ganz so talentiert. Dann war das Fußballspielen natürlich auf der einen Seite total einfach. Das, was mich am Anfang überrascht hat, war die Empfindlichkeit in der Liga. Also die Temperaturen sind brutal. Die laufen aber trotzdem gefühlt dreimal so viel wie in der Bundesliga. Und die hauen sich rein wie Bekloppte. Also das ist wirklich fast so eine Rugby-Attitude. Da wusste ich teilweise gar nicht, welche Sportart wir spielen. Also da ging es gerade in der Anfangszeit noch sowas von hart zu, also wirklich Grätschen, die baldweinig auf Kniehöhe angeflogen kamen. Und jedes Kopfball-Duell war irgendwie gefühlt eine Schlacht.
Aber dann hast du dich ja gut gewöhnen können an die Liga. Ich glaube, den Bezug, den die meisten Hörerinnen und Hörer zu dir haben und auch ich, ist diese Doku, die es über dich gibt von Alyosha Pause, Tom Miecizu. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das Thema überhaupt noch hören kannst. Was hat denn diese Doku, die dich ja schon einer fußballinteressierten Öffentlichkeit so ein bisschen ins Rampenlicht gestellt hat, obwohl du so ein bisschen von der Bildfläche verschwunden warst, für alle Bundesliga-Affinen-Fans? Was hat denn die Doku für dich so verändert?
Die Doku war eigentlich für mich so eine Gelegenheit, auch mit meinem Leben so ein bisschen aufzuweinen. Weil ich ja ganz viel auch immer wieder zusammenfassen musste und mich auch selber beschrieben musste. Und ich konnte dann eigentlich ganz gut nachvollziehen, so gerade ein bisschen Abstand, was mit und in mir auch so passiert ist. Und ich glaube, es hat mir auch ein Stück weit dabei geholfen, ein bisschen reifer und erwachsener zu werden. Also irgendwann war halt sehr, sehr klar, dass ich mir im Prinzip selber sehr für den Weg gestanden bin. Und ja, dann muss man auch sagen, mit diesem schönen Happy End und allem, was dazu kam, wurde am Ende noch irgendwie auch eine coole Geschichte, die man auch gern erzählte, die sich Leute gern anhören. Also am Ende war das eine Sache, die mir echt auch gut getan hat.
Ja, also das muss man dazu sagen. Du wurdest eben begleitet von Aljoscha Pause von 2003 bis 2011, sagt mir Wikipedia, also definitiv über einen sehr langen Zeitraum. Wann kam denn dann eigentlich die Entscheidung, okay, jetzt machen wir da draus ein fertiges Paket und veröffentlichen es, weil deine Karriere war ja noch lange nicht vorbei und ist sie ja im Grunde jetzt auch nicht. Du hast ja jetzt auch noch – es ist ja nicht so, dass man dann irgendwann sagt, okay, gut, ab jetzt erlebe ich nichts mehr.
Ja, das war definitiv der Schritt nach Australien, der uns dazu zurückbringt, das Ganze zu Ende zu bringen. Die Zahl in der Bundesliga war definitiv einfach abgelaufen. Und dann kam dieses Abenteuer um die Ecke und auch irgendwie war das in sich stimmig, weil ich ja ganz früh auch schon gesagt habe, dass ich ganz gern auch im Ausland spielen würde. Jetzt hatte ich damals natürlich eher an Frankreich gesagt oder Spanien auf entsprechenden Niveau, aber Australien war quasi gut enough für mich. Das ist irgendwie eine coole Geschichte. Ich schaffte es doch noch ins Ausland und wir machen jetzt die Sache rund.
Und was machst du jetzt gerade? Wir sprechen ja gerade nicht über eine Telefonleitung, die bis nach Australien reicht.
Ich sitze tatsächlich wieder in Köln, ich habe drei Jahre hier gespielt und es hat mich in der Stadt unfassbar wohlgefühlt. Und ich hatte darüber hinaus noch das Glück, das hier nicht nur geil zu finden, sondern die DSL ist hier auch noch ansässig, die für das englischsprachige Ausland Bundesliga produziert. Also sprich, die heulen ihre eigenen Kommentatoren aus England vorwiegend an und setzen da dann ehemalige Bundesligaspieler daneben, die noch so ein bisschen Englisch sprechen können.
Kannst du denn Englisch sprechen? Du warst doch in Australien, du musst doch einen fürchterlichen Dialekt haben.
Das kriege ich schon aufzuhören. Das ist eine ganz witzige Geschichte, dass ich ab und an tatsächlich Bundesligaspiele kommentiere, die dann in Thailand, Indien und so weiter zu hören sind. Viele meiner ehemaligen Mitspieler aus Brüssel tummeln sich in diesen Ländern herum. Die finden das total geil, wenn sie total unverhofft und für später Stunde über meine Stimme stolpern.
Sehr gut, das kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Was würdest du denn jetzt in der Retrospective, das Australienkapitel ist jetzt erst mal abgeschlossen, das waren eben sieben Jahre, wie würdest du denn diese ganze Liga einordnen? Du hast es jetzt schon sportlich eingeordnet, also irgendwo so untere zweite Liga hast du gesagt. Was ist denn mit dem ganzen Drum herum, mit dem Zuschauerzuspruch, mit der Art und Weise, wie dort trainiert wird? Wie sehr unterscheidet sich das von dem, was man hier in Deutschland unter Profifußball versteht?
Also da muss man wirklich unterscheiden. Das eine ist die Art, wie inhaltlich gearbeitet wird. Da unterscheidet sich das kaum. Also von den professionellen Rahmenbedingungen ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen kleiner. Aber wir nehmen das genauso ernst. Also die trainieren eigentlich im gleichen Umfang mit entsprechender Betreuung. Also Ärzte, Physios, Sport, Science ist bei denen wirklich auch ein Riesending, da wird Australien auch führend. Das heißt, du hast nämlich viele Tests und mehr begleitende Maßnahmen zum Training. Also Pre-Hab, Re-Hab, diese Sachen, GPS, Monitoring und all diese Geschichten. Also da sind die wirklich ganz dick vorne mit dabei. Was natürlich die nicht leisten können, ist irgendwie diese mediale Aufmerksamkeit, die Wichtigkeit des Fußballs. Also du hast dann nur das Gefühl, dass du eher bei einem Amateurverein spielst, gehst zum Training und es ist einfach ein superschöner Tag und außer der Mannschaft ist keiner da. Das wird ja in der Form in der Bundesliga überhaupt nicht geben. Dass es mal einen Tag in der Plattform gibt, sagen wir mal am Mittwoch, wo gar nicht über den Verein geschrieben wird. Also das ist dann zum Spielzeug hin was anderes, aber es gibt halt echt, wenn man sich das jetzt vorstellen würde, die Bildzeitung würde einen Tag nicht über, also nicht Köln schreiben oder so. Das wäre total undenkbar. In Australien ist das eben noch denkbar.
Aber gibt es da eine Entwicklung, die andeutet, dass der Fußball da wichtiger wird oder wird man immer in dieser Nische bleiben, was ja für sich genommen auch nicht schlimm ist? Man muss ja nicht immer die tollste und größte Sportart der Welt sein.
Nein, man muss wirklich sagen, die Liga hat sich krass entwickelt. Also jetzt im Moment gibt es wieder so einen leichten Rückgang, würde ich schon fast sagen, was das im Press sein wird und auch die Qualitäterliga. Aber wahrscheinlich nur, weil die letzten Jahre extreme Boomjahre waren. Was vom sportlichen Niveau her ziemlich geil für australische Verhältnisse, sondern plötzlich so Leute wie Harry Kuhl, Dave Piavo, Emil Heske darum laufen. Thomas Broich. Genau, der Fußball hat sich entwickelt von Kick and Rush hin zu, ja, also versuchten Tiki-Taka, langsamer so. Da war dann auch der ehemalige Chef der La Masia-Akademie aus Barcelona, war dann Trainer in Adelaide, mit dem dann Meister geworden. Solche Geschichten, wo wirklich ein bisschen Fußball-Know-how auch reingekommen ist und das haben die Leute natürlich auch geil. Aber jetzt die letzten 2, 3 Jahre geht es ein bisschen wieder in die andere Richtung. Und ja, also es steht und fällt, muss man leider auch sagen, viel mit dem Abschneiden der australischen Nationalmannschaft. Also wenn die Australier das Gefühl haben, dass sie absolut konverenzfähig sind, international, dann rennen sie auch in der Liga die Bude ein. Also als Australien 2006, ich glaube bis ins 8. oder 4. Finale gekommen ist, da hatten wir jetzt in der Liga einen Zuschauerschnitt von 20.000.
Und wie macht dann die aktuelle australische Nationalmannschaft da wirbel? Also man hat ja die Qualifikation wieder geschafft, ist in einer WM-Gruppe mit Frankreich, Dänemark und Peru. Wie weit man da kommt, muss man sehen. Aber wie würdest du da die aktuelle Nationalmannschaft einordnen? Schwierig für die im Moment.
Also die goldene Generation, die hat ja mittlerweile fast kollektiv abgegangen. Kimi Kehil läuft da noch ein bisschen mit. Der war mittlerweile 38, immer noch wichtig, aber auch nicht mehr der Spieler, der irgendwann mal war. Und was da so nachkommt, ist halt echt überschaubar. Also ich würde sagen, dann hat Aaron Moy da ein Hattas-Film drum laufen, der echt kicken kann, aber ansonsten, ja, so würde ich sagen, die haben ja kaum einen Spieler, der in einer europäischen Top-Liga spielt.
Matthew Leckie, vielleicht noch der bekannteste, den man dann auch hierzulande kennt. Und ich habe noch mal gerade nachgeguckt, Australien, damals WM 2006, das war dieses Achtelfinale gegen Italien, was man ganz unglücklich durch diesen Strafstoß mit 0 zu 1 verloren hat, wo ich auch bis heute sagen würde, naja, den muss man nicht geben, da halb Zucker in, halb Sanker hin, so ein Strafstoß war das. Genau, das war das große Boomjahr des australischen Fußballs. Würdest du denn noch mal zurückgehen nach Australien, in die Liga in irgendeiner Funktion?
Die Ausflüchen, wie gesagt, also von der Liga her spannend, es wird auch professionell gearbeitet und der Fußball ist ja wirklich, ja, also da entsteht auch richtig, das kann man wirklich auch sagen. Und mit meinen Ambitionen, also ich möchte wirklich auch Trainer werden, könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, da vielleicht dann sogar erste Erfahrung zusammen.
Wie sehr macht da das unterschiedliche Ligensystem Unterschied zu dem, was man hier wahrscheinlich als Bundesligatrainer hat? Also in der Regular-Season spielen alle Teams dreimal gegeneinander und dann gibt es eben dieses Playoff-System, ein bisschen kompliziert, der Meister und der Dritte und Vierte, die spielen dann aus, wer in den Semifinals auftritt. Und vorher gibt es noch so eine Eliminierungsrunde, kann man sich im Detail angucken. Aber es gibt ja keinen anderen KO-Wettbewerb, außer man kommt eben irgendwie in die AFC Champions League. Das heißt, man hat nur im Wochenrhythmus Spiele in Australien.
Da sind dann alle am Mannschaften mit drin, also im GV-Vokal. Aber erst seit kurzem, also ich glaube jetzt im dritten Jahr, vielleicht vierten, ist eine relativ junge Geschichte. Aber selbst da, also in Australien spielst du ja nicht so viele Spiele. Im Prinzip ist das wirklich im Wochenrhythmus. Und das ist ja auch eine relativ kleine Liga, eine relativ kurze Saison. Das heißt, du hast da, also die Jungs, die haben jetzt ja de facto Sommer- oder Winterpause, je nachdem, wer das nennen will. Und fangen dann wahrscheinlich im Juli wieder im Training an. Und dann erst im September, Oktober wieder mit der Liga. Also das ist eine unfassbar lange Vorbereitung.
Und dann wöchentliche Spiele. Das heißt ja eigentlich für den Trainer Novizen die idealen Voraussetzungen. Du hast genügend Zeit für Regeneration, um Dinge einzustudieren. Du hast auch genügend Zeit Spiele zu analysieren und vorzubereiten. Das hört sich echt ganz gut an. Aber wäre deine Sorge nicht so ein bisschen, dass du da dann unter dem Radar liefst? Jetzt so von Deutschland aus betrachtet?
Überhaupt nicht. Also ich glaube, das wäre eine super Möglichkeit, einfach das Handwerk zu erlernen. Einfach zu erfahren, wie das ist, mit der Mannschaft zusammen zu arbeiten und trotzdem unter professionellen Bedingungen zu arbeiten. Und gerade die Voraussetzungen da unten. Also es ist einfach medial eine andere Geschichte. Der Druck ist einfach nicht so groß. Das heißt, es müsste schon mit dem Teufel zugehen, dass du da gefeuert bist. Also selbst wenn du in Australien wochenlang…
Was für ein Satz, Wahnsinn. Gut, aber es gibt ja auch keinen Abstieg.
Ganz genau. Und dann wird viel erzählt von Entwicklungen und so weiter. Also ein Trainer kann eine ganze Saison unten stehen und immer versprechen, dass es nur eine Übergangs-Saison ist und im nächsten Jahr wird alles gut. Der kriegt das unter Umständen noch verkauft. Also das kann man sich in Deutschland gar nicht vorstellen. Und dann die Tatsache, dass es halt diese unfassbar lange Vorbereitung gibt. Also gerade wenn du als Trainer irgendwie neu bist und in eine Mannschaft zusammenstellst und hast die Zeit, auch gewisse Automatismen einzuüben, dass dann im Level playing fühlt, wenn du ja so gleiche Voraussetzungen gibst. Das ist die Gehaltsobergrenze. Das heißt, du spielst jetzt nicht gefühlt gegen Bayern und Dortmund in der Liga, sondern jede Mannschaft ist einfach Frankfurt oder Hertha. Also im Prinzip sind alle so auf Augenhöhe. Und derjenige, der die wirklich beste Arbeit macht in dem Jahr, ist dann halt einfach vorne dran. Für einen jungen Trainer sind das super Voraussetzungen.
Das sind ehrlich gesagt auch für die Zuschauer und Fans super Voraussetzungen. Da läuft einem ja fast das Wasser im Mund zusammen, wenn man sich das mit der aktuellen Bundesligatabelle vergleicht. Also da hätte ich lieber 18 Herthers oder Eintracht Frankfurt. Und dann kommt derjenige als Sieger raus, der die beste Arbeit macht, als halt ein deutscher Meister mit 24 Punkten Vorsprung auf den Tabellen 2. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Ich vermute mal nicht nur dadurch, dass du in Köln jetzt wieder wohnst, sondern auch durch deine Zeit damals wirst du noch einen Bezug zum FC haben. Wie siehst du denn noch so ganz kurz die Situation beim FC in der 1. Liga bzw. ja jetzt dann bei 2. Liga? Das tut jetzt vielen sehr weh, dass du das sagst, weil wir dachten alle oder viele dachten, ach der FC, jetzt ist er ruhiger geworden und man arbeitet da kontinuierlich und es ist alles nicht so aufgeregt und innerhalb von einer Hinrunde, dieses Kartenhaus fiel in sich zusammen.
Das Lustige ist ja, dass ich diese Phase eigentlich gar nicht mitbekommen habe. Also man erzählt es mir so. Dann komme ich quasi in Deutschland an und dann haben die kurz vor Weihnachten drei Punkte, hauen den Trainer raus, steigen als Europapokal-Teilnehmer ab. Total verrückt, aber dann auch das Positive, dass man hier in der Stadt einfach erlebt, wie unfassbar krass die Liebe für diesen Verein ist und was die alles verzeihen eigentlich. Und dann jetzt diese treue Bekenntnis, nicht nur Bekenntnisse der Spieler, sondern dass die da wirklich auch mit in die zweite Liga gehen, neue Verträge in der Zweitliga unterschreiben. Also es ist wirklich ein einmaliger Verein, aber es ist halt leider bezeichnend, dass sie jetzt wieder abgestiegen sind.
Ja, so genau versteht das, glaube ich, keiner. Aber da höre ich noch jede Menge Begeisterung raus. Was machst du denn jetzt dann, wenn du nicht gerade irgendwelche deutschen Bundesligaspiele als englischsprachiger Experte mitbegleitest? Hospitierst du auch bei Profivereinen? Guckst du mal jetzt Stefan Rutenberg oder bald Markus Anfang über die Schulter, was er so beim FC trainieren lässt? Wie sind so deine nächsten Pläne?
Ich habe das von Australien sogar schon begonnen. Also ich habe mir vorher mal angedeutet, drei wirklich super Trainer. Nicht nur Trainer, die ich selber hatte, sondern auch gegen, die ich gespielt habe. Und von denen habe ich mir den Fristball schon mal ein bisschen erklären lassen. Und habe in Deutschland auch schon hospitiert, bei einem DFB-Stützpunkt und möchte das auch weiterhin machen.
Das hört sich super spannend an. Thomas, ich würde sagen, wenn du irgendwann mal vier bis fünf Stündchen Zeit hast, dann komme ich mal nach Köln und dann reden wir mal über deine Karriere und machen dann ein Karriere-Intribümgespräch draus. Das kennst du jetzt noch nicht, das ist das etwas längere Format des Rasenfunks. Danke dir, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast. Das war Thomas Broich, vielen, vielen Dank dir. Du bist ja nicht auf Twitter oder so aktiv, dass man dir folgen könnte. Das ist schade für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer. Na ja, dann seid ihr einfach sicher, ich bin mir sicher, viele haben sich jetzt gefreut, dich mal wieder zu hören. Und in diesem Sinne, danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, fürs Zuhören. Das war Kurzpass Nummer 55. Die nächste Schlusskonferenz erscheint am Sonntag. Ein neues Tribüngengespräch gibt es am Montag oder Dienstag. Und dann steht ja schon der Rasenfunk-Royal an. Meine Güte, es sind bewegte Zeiten. Ach ja, und dann kommt die WM-Vorschau. Also, so wirklich Urlaub gibt es nicht. Wenn ihr unterstützen möchtet, dass das alles so hinhaut, auch finanziell, dann geht auf rasenfunk.de slash unterstützen. Und ansonsten wünsche ich euch eine wunderbare Zeit. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao.